kerzengerade und majestätisch zwölf
meter hoch und vier meter breit ist der
weihnachtsbaum vor schloss windsor
der haupt residenz von königin elizabeth
der zweite die nordmanntanne stammt aus
der heimatstadt ihres ururgroßvaters
[Musik]
weihnachtsansprache davon berichtet dass
der weihnachtsbaum der anfangs coburg
kommt als damals albert die queen
victoria geheiratet hat und es haben die
mitarbeiter aufgenommen und dann kam die
idee lasst uns darum brief an die queen
schreiben und die ein weihnachtsbaum
finden im november 2015 wurde die idee
umgesetzt
die stadt coburg schrieb einen brief an
die queen und bot einen weihnachtsbaum
aus dem coburger wäldern samt
baumschmuck an die antwort aus dem
buckingham palast ließ nicht lange auf
sich warten
die queen sagte kommt jetzt nicht zurück
in windsor auch die bürgermeisterin des
kleinen ortes westlich von london ist es
ist eine große ehre so etwas aus
deutschland für großbritannien zu
bekommen vor allem in unserer stadt
winzer wir fühlen uns sehr privilegiert
den baum hierzu haben vor allem auch mit
all der dekoration
er sieht toll aus und so fing alles an
königin victoria ehelichte albert von
sachsen coburg und gotha
der deutsche brachte 1848 den ersten
weihnachtsbaum nach england so wurde der
baum teil der britische weihnachts
tradition
victoria und albert sind die
ururgroßeltern von königin elisabeth der
zweiten geboren wurde prinzgemahl albert
hier auf schloss rosenau bei coburg im
jahr 1819 noch heute lebt ein teil der
familie in dieser gegend so auch
airprint zu werten er hat den
weihnachtsbaum für die queen gespendet
uns wurde gesagt zwischen zehn und zwölf
meter in die höhe war auch nicht so sehr
das thema es war er das thema die breite
er durfte maximalen durchmesser vier
meter haben
da an dem standort wo er aufgestellt
wird am schloss windsor direkt hinter
der queen victoria statue auch einen
changing the gold durchgeführt wird und
dort natürlich die wachen noch
durchkommen müssen ohne den baum zu
berühren das war eine gewisse
herausforderung einen baum zu finden der
eben diese höhe hat aber maximal die
breite wir haben es geschafft aber ganz
toll gerade gewachsenen baum gefunden
und sind sehr froh darüber
die rund 30 jahre alte nordmanntanne
wird im coburger wald gefällt und
offiziell verabschiedet von der
bayerischen provinz startet eine rund
1000 kilometer lange reise über den
ärmelkanal nach großbritannien
ein paar tage später die tanne hat die
fahrt gut überstanden und thront nun vor
dem schloss windsor
die residenz der britischen monarchen
ist das größte und älteste durchgängig
bewohnte schloss der welt und
hauptwohnsitz der krieg dass der
weihnachtsbaum dieses jahr aus kuba
kommt ist kein zufall
es wird in coburg der 210 geburtstag von
prinz albert gefeiert mit jetzt schon in
planung befindlichen veranstaltungen und
da haben wir einen großen wunsch ein
großes ziel einen großen traum
vielleicht sogar wenn es uns gelingt
dann in zwei jahren jemand von der
königlichen familie in coburg begrüßen
zu dürfen dann war das ein richtig
voller erfolg
damit die bescherung perfekt ist wird
der weihnachtsbaum traditionell
geschmückt mit rund 2.000
weihnachtskugeln aus lauscha die
deutsche stadt in der nähe von coburg
ist weltberühmt fingen glasschmuck mehr
als ein halbes jahr arbeit steckt dieser
dekoration etwas ganz besonderes ist es
weil die kugeln handgemacht sind wir
haben diese kugel auch aus über 30
jahren alten klaus früheren hergestellt
die früher in der nähe von lauter
hergestellt worden sind
zwei tage lang dauert es bis alle kugeln
und kerzen am baum fest angebracht sind
der weihnachtsbaum der queen ist der
neue star von windsor und zieht alle
blicke auf sich
es ist herrlich vor dem schloss es ist
wunderschön
ich mag den baum er ist groß und gut
proportioniert einfach großartig ist
sehr schön es ist magisch
bis anfang januar kann diese schönheit
noch im winter bewundert werden
[Musik]